ou, mieux encore, nous pouvons entendre dire certaines choses
que bien souvent les femmes ne peuvent pas entendre dire.
Maintenant, je comprend que c'est un problème. C'est du sexisme.
Mais c'est la vérité. Et donc une des choses que je dis aux hommes
et à mes collègues, ce que je leur dis toujours,
c'est que nous avons besoin de plus d'hommes qui ont le courage et la force
pour commencer à se lever et dire certaines de ces choses,
être aux côtés des femmes et non contre elles
à prétendre que d'une certaine façon c'est
une bataille entre les sexes et d'autres sortes d'absurdité.
Nous vivons ensemble dans le monde.
Et au fait, une des choses qui m'ennuie vraiment
à propos de cette rhétorique contre les féministes et les autres
est que nous avons construit les mouvements de femmes battues
et de victimes de viols dans le monde
est que quelque part, comme je l'ai dit, c'est qu'elle sont anti-hommes.
Qu'en est-il des garçons qui sont profondément affectés
d'une façon négative par ce qu'un homme adulte est en train
de faire à leur mère, à eux-mêmes, à leurs sœurs ?
Qu'en est-il de tous ces garçons ?
Qu'en est-il de ces jeunes hommes et de ces garçons
qui ont été traumatisés par la violence d'hommes adultes ?
Vous savez quoi ? Le même système qui produit
des hommes qui maltraitent des femmes, produit des hommes qui maltraitent d'autres hommes.
Et si nous voulons parler des victimes hommes,
parlons des victimes hommes.
La plupart des victimes hommes de violence sont des victimes de la violence d'autres hommes.
C'est donc quelque chose que les hommes et les femmes ont en commun.
Nous sommes tous les deux victimes de la violence des hommes.
C'est donc notre propre intérêt direct,
sans parler du fait que la plupart des hommes que je connais
ont des femmes et des filles auxquelles ils tiennent beaucoup,
dans nos familles et nos groupes d'amis...
Il y a donc tant de raisons pour lesquelles nous avons besoin que les hommes parlent.
Ça paraît évident en le disant à haute voix. N'est-ce pas ?
Maintenant, la nature du travail que je fais avec mes collègues
dans le monde sportif, l'armée américaine, dans les écoles,
nous avons été les pionniers de l'approche appelée l'approche du curieux
pour la prévention de la violence sexiste.
Je veux seulement vous donner les grands titres de cette approche du curieux
parce que c'est un gros changement thématique,
bien qu'il y ait beaucoup de détails,
mais le cœur de ça, c'est qu'au lieu de voir les hommes comme les coupables
et les femmes comme les victimes,
ou les femmes comme les coupables et les hommes victimes,
ou tout autre combinaison.
J'utilise le binaire du genre. Je sais qu'il y a plus
que des hommes et des femmes, il y a plus que masculin et féminin.
Il y a aussi des femmes qui sont coupables
et bien sûr il y a des hommes qui sont victimes.
Il y a un large spectre.
Mais au lieu de le voir à la mode binaire,
on se concentre sur nous tous avec ce qu'on appelle les curieux,
et un curieux est défini comme n'importe qui qui n'est pas
un coupable ou une victime dans une situation donnée,
en d'autres termes, les amis, les copains, les collègues,
les membre de la famille, ceux d'entre nous
qui ne sont pas directement impliqués dans un dyade d'abus,
mais qui sont intégrés dans une culture sociale, familiale, du travail, scolaire,
et avec d'autres paires avec des gens
qui pourraient être dans cette situation. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Comment est-ce qu'on en parle ? Comment on met au défi nos amis ?
Comment soutient-on nos amis ? Comment ne pas
rester silencieux face aux abus ?
Maintenant, lorsqu'il s'agit des hommes et de la culture masculine,
le but est d'amener les hommes qui ne sont pas abusifs
à défier les hommes qui le sont.
Lorsque je dis abusif, je ne veux pas seulement dire
les hommes qui frappent les femmes.
Nous ne sommes pas seulement en train de dire qu'un homme dont l'ami
abuse de sa petite amie doit arrêter le type
au moment de l'attaque.
C'est une façon naïve de créer un changement social.
C'est le long d'un continuum que nous essayons d'avoir des hommes
pour s'interrompre mutuellement.
Donc, par exemple, si vous êtes un gars et que vous êtes dans un groupe de gars
jouant au poker, parlant, sortant, sans femme présente
et qu'un autre gars dit quelque chose de sexiste ou dégradant
ou qui harcèle les femmes;
au lieu de rire avec eux ou prétendre que vous n'avez rien entendu,
nous avons besoin d'hommes pour dire, « Hey, ce n'est pas drôle.
Tu sais, tu pourrais être en train de parler de ma soeur
et tu ne pourrais pas faire des blagues sur autre chose ?
Ou pourrais-tu parler d'autre chose ?
Je n'apprécie pas ce genre de discussion. »
Comme si vous étiez une personne blanche et qu'une autre personne blanche
fait un commentaire raciste, vous espérez, j'espère,
que les gens blancs interrompraient cette représentation raciste
par une personne blanche.
Tout comme l’hétéro-sexisme, si vous êtes une personne hétérosexuelle
et que vous même n'édicter pas de comportement harcelant ou abusif
envers les personnes d'orientations sexuelles variées,
si vous ne dites pas quelque chose en face des autres hétérosexuels,
alors, dans un sens, votre silence
n'est-il pas une forme de consentement et de complicité ?
Et bien, l'approche du curieux essaye de donner au gens les moyens
d'interrompre ce processus et de s'exprimer
en créant un climat de culture des pairs
où les comportements abusifs sont vus comme inacceptables,
pas seulement parce que c'est illégal, mais parce que c'est mauvais
et inacceptable dans la culture des pairs.
Si nous pouvons atteindre le moment où les hommes
qui agissent comme des misogynes perdent leur statut,
les jeunes hommes et les garçons qui agissent de façon
sexiste et qui harcèlent les filles et les femmes,
aussi bien envers les autres garçons et hommes,
perdront ainsi leur statut, devinez quoi ?
On verra une diminution drastique des abus.
Parce que le coupable typique n'est pas malade ou tordu.
C'est un type normal dans tous les aspects. Non ?
Maintenant, parmi les nombreuses grandes choses que Martin Luther King
a dit dans sa courte vie, il y avait,
« A la fin, ce qui fera le plus de mal
n'est pas les mots de nos ennemies
mais le silence de nos amis. »
A la fin, ce qui fera le plus de mal ce n'est pas les mots
de nos ennemies mais le silence de nos amis.
Il y a eu beaucoup de silence dans la culture masculine
concernant les tragédies actuelles de la violence des hommes
envers les femmes et les enfants, n'est-ce pas ?
Il y a eu énormément de silence.
Et tout ce que je dit c'est que nous avons besoin de briser ce silence,
et nous avons besoin de plus d'hommes pour faire ça.
Maintenant, c'est plus facile à dire qu'à faire,
parce que je vous le dit maintenant, mais je vous dit que ce n'est pas facile
dans les cultures des hommes de se défier les uns les autres,
ce qui est une des raisons pour laquelle
une partie de ce changement de paradigme qui doit avoir lieu
n'est pas seulement la compréhension de ces problèmes en tant que problèmes d'hommes,
mais également des problèmes de leadership pour les hommes.
Parce que finalement, la responsabilité de prendre partie
sur ces problèmes ne devrait pas tomber sur les épaules
de jeunes garçons ou d'adolescents au lycée
ou d'étudiants. Çà devrait être sur celles d'hommes avec du pouvoir.
Les hommes adultes avec du pouvoir sont ceux dont nous avons besoin pour être tenus responsables
d'être des leaders concernant ces problèmes,
parce que lorsque quelqu'un parle auprès des siens
les défie et les interrompt, il ou elle
devient un leader, vraiment, non ?
Mais à une grande échelle, nous avons besoin de plus d'hommes avec le pouvoir
pour commencer à prioriser ses sujets,
nous ne l'avons pas encore vu, n'est-ce pas ?
Maintenant, j'étais à un dîner il y a de nombreuses années,
et je travaille beaucoup avec l'armée américaine, avec tous les services.
J'étais à ce dîner et cette femme m'a dit --
je pense qu'elle trouvait qu'elle était intelligente -- elle a dit,
« Depuis combien de temps faites vous des formations à la sensibilité
avec les Marines ? »
Et j'ai répondu, « Avec tout mon respect,
je ne fait pas de formation à la sensibilité avec les Marines.
Je conduit des programmes de leadership dans le corps des Marines. »
Maintenant, je sais que c'est un peu pompeux, ma réponse,
mais c'est une distinction importante, parce que je ne crois pas
que nous avons besoin de formation à la sensibilité.
Nous avons besoin de formation au leadership, parce que, par exemple
lorsqu'un coach professionnel ou le manager d'une équipe de baseball
ou d'une équipe de football -- et je travaille énormément dans ce domaine également --
fait des remarques sexistes, fait des déclarations homophobes,
fait des commentaires racistes, il y aura des discussions
sur les blogs de sports et dans les commentaires de sport à la radio.
Et certaines personnes diront, « Bien, il a besoin d'une formation à la sensibilité. »
Et d'autres diront, « Bien, descendons le.
Vous savez, c'est un terme politiquement correct pour devenir fou furieux,
il a agit stupidement. Passons à autre chose. »
Mon argument est qu'il n'a pas besoin de formation à la sensibilité.
Il a besoin de formation au leadership,
parce que c'est un mauvais leader, parce que dans une société
avec une diversité de genres et d'orientation sexuelle --
(Applaudissements) --
une diversité raciale et ethnique, si vous faites
ce genre de commentaire, vous manquez de leadership.
Si on peut arriver à ce point qui consiste à
placer des hommes et des femmes puissantes dans notre société
à tous les niveaux de l'autorité institutionnelle et du pouvoir,
ça va changer, ça va changer
le paradigme de ce que les gens pensent.
Vous savez, par exemple, j'ai beaucoup travaillé
dans l'athlétisme universitaire et scolaire en Amérique du Nord.
Nous savons tellement de chose sur le prévention
de la violence sexuelle et domestique, non ?
Il n'y a aucune excuse pour une faculté ou une université
de ne pas avoir de formation à la prévention de la violence domestique et sexuelle
obligatoire pour tous les athlètes étudiants, les coachs, les administrateurs,
dans le cadre de leur cursus éducatif.
Nous en savons assez pour savoir que nous pouvons le faire facilement.
Mais vous savez ce qui manque ? Du leadership.
Mais ce n'est pas le leadership des athlètes étudiants.
C'est le leadership des directeurs sportifs,
du président de l'université, des personnes en charge
qui prennent des décisions sur le recrutement
et ceux qui prennent des décisions sur les priorités dans le cadre institutionnel.
C'est un manque, dans la plupart des cas, de leadership masculin.
Regarder à Penn State. Penn State est la mère
de tous les instants propices à l'approche du spectateur.
Il y a tant de situations dans ce domaine
où les hommes en position de force échouent à agir
pour protéger les enfants, dans ce cas, les garçons.
C'est incroyable, vraiment. Mais quand vous y êtes,
vous comprenez que les hommes subissent des pressions.
Ils sont contraints au sein de leur paires
et c'est pour ça que nous devons encourager ces hommes
à briser ces pressions.
Et un des moyens de faire ça est de dire
qu'il y a un paquet d'hommes qui s'intéressent vraiment à ces problèmes.
Je sais ça. Je travaille avec des hommes,
et j'ai travaillé avec des dizaines de milliers,
des centaines de milliers d'hommes pendant de nombreuses, nombreuses décennies maintenant.
C'est effrayant, quand on pense à toutes ces années.
Mais il y a tant d'hommes qui s'intéressent sincèrement à ces problèmes
mais s'intéresser sincèrement n'est pas suffisant.
Nous avons besoin d'hommes avec plus de cran,
avec le courage, la force, et l'intégrité
de briser notre silence complice, se défier les uns les autres
et se tenir auprès des femmes et non contre elles.
Au fait, nous le devons aux femmes.
Il n'y a aucun doute la-dessus.
Mais nous le devons aussi à nos enfants.
Nous le devons aussi à tous les jeunes hommes qui grandissent
partout dans le monde dans des situations où ils n'ont pas eu le choix
d'être un homme dans une culture qui leur décrit
la virilité d'une certaine façon.
Ils n'ont pas fait ce choix.
Nous avons le choix, nous avons l'opportunité
et une responsabilité envers eux également.
J'espère que, en allant de l'avant, les hommes et les femmes,
en travaillant ensemble, peuvent initier le changement
et que la transformation aura lieu
de sorte que les futures générations n'auront pas le niveau de tragédie
auquel nous sommes confrontés tous les jours.
Je sais que nous pouvons le faire. Nous pouvons faire mieux.
Merci beaucoup. (Applaudissements)